the jurogan experience
he doesn't look happy wow and that
living in 1901 [ __ ]
yeah average life expected he's 40 years
old average like 60 like 44 45
really at that time i mean but if you
make it past childbirth of course you
have a better much better chance of of
surviving but
but anyway he does name his company
after his wife what's interesting is
you wonder whether that was like whether
she'd be happy about that it becomes
this hated name in so many ways years
later but he's scrapping by he actually
had tried to start a chemical industry
in the late 19th century it had burned
down
and he didn't have any money he's got
these kids he's got his family so like
to your point i'm kind of when i'm
reading this i'm trying to understand
how is this company starting what's the
human story here how do we get into this
mess
you know money
and then you know we do when you get as
you said to the 50s and 60s these
agricultural chemicals become a huge
part of their business
but kind of back to roundup
70.
okay
245t now now the lid's off you know the
government's starting to find out about
it people are raising alarms scientists
are talking about how toxic this stuff
is
and
you know they're looking for an
alternative something that's not as
toxic as this stuff
and that's when john franz finds
uh glyphosate interestingly
you know all like the detergent all yes
that was a monsanto product of course it
was
but it had it had a phosphate based
ingredient in it that helped it
clean clothes
but in the 60s
phosphate based detergents were ending
up in waterways and contributing to like
fish algae blooms and fish stuff yeah
and so they had to get rid of that
phosphate detergent and they had all
this phosphate
and they're like what do we do with all
this phosphate
boom all detergent you know and all that
phosphate ends up becoming the building
blocks of roundup roundup is ultimately
coming from elemental phosphorus
wow it's crazy and but it was all
designed to be healthy
i knew a guy who lived in a community
that was uh connected to a golf course
and he grew up drinking water from a
well and him and
a large number of people in the
community got cancer
and they firmly believed that it was
because of whatever pesticides that they
were using or herbicides that they were
using on the golf course that it leaked
into the wells
can i show you what roundup looks like
nowadays
jamie there's a there's a map in there
that's like a map of the country and
it's kind of brown
and it shows you
kind of roundup um probably mostly
it says glyphosate because that's the
active ingredient but i just want to
show you the change that's happened over
the last several years with glyphosate
so like
that's glyphosate this comes from the
usgs pesticide national synthesis
program um
this is what happened with
roundup ready technology like we were
this is 92. so remember i said roundup
is created in the 70s but it's not
really used that much you know
throughout the growing season it's
interesting how it's used so much in
california yeah it's a primary
application of it that that's that the
weird farmland on the way up to san
francisco if you're driving from la and
you see you know like [ __ ] joe biden
signs that's where they are
exactly
yep that's also you know the land of
like
like 90 percent of our almonds like you
know
all the salad everything comes in there
yeah and so much pesticide use in
that valley wow but look at the midwest
i mean it goes from like
you know almost none almost very little
to
swarm to swarms and 2007 and that's
because you've made crops that are now
resistant to glyphosate so you can spray
it
all you know as much as you need to kill
your weeds
but
um and jamie there's
you had that weed resistance graph going
up but a fifth grader can tell you well
wow when you spray that much roundup
on something or glyphosate on something
you're gonna start seeing
resistance adaptation exactly like it's
nature fighting back like what's
happening with um antibiotics where
you're seeing these like mrsa like these
medication resistant staph infections
that are insanely difficult to treat
just like it yeah just like it you know
in fact some of the weed scientists i
talked to
i'll be honest the when i first was
going to a talk at ohio state that they
said the weed scientists are talking i
thought oh
i thought
marijuana showed up i was like oh this
is cool too you know yeah i want to find
out how to make the [ __ ] stronger
so
but these weed scientists at ohio state
who are great and helped out with the
book um fantastic folks you know some of
those you know they're like glyphosate
was like penicillin man it was it was so
powerful it was so effective at killing
weeds that like and we burned through it
because these weeds became resistant to
it
and so
and that's where we're at now kind of
going back to your point about
chemicals and exposures like
roundup was introduced because it was
seen as
an environmentally more friendly
herbicide at the time in the 70s than
age and art and then
yeah you're comparing it against a
pretty bad uh it's like would you like
to get punched or shoot you
and you know it had to do with you know
the way it worked and the mechanisms
there but what's happening now because
of that resistance and jamie i hate to
bring it up again because it's actually
kind of cool you get to see this this
first time we put it together but when
that weed resistance takes off i think
it's the next graph after that
what what happens is
check this out okay this is this is
what's happening i put this together
with a friend of mine who's data
scientist try to uh remember that a lot
of people are just listening they're
just a huge percentage it's fair enough
so i'll try and describe it so what
we're looking at is pounds of herbicide
per acre of soybeans so it's just
looking at soybeans as a case study and
we're looking at the amount of
herbicides that's being used on farms
per acre
in the u.s in specific states just
because they had
data for this to for us to compare and
what we're seeing is this like explosion
in roundup glyphosate that big dark line
going up like that and notice look
we we started seeing the decline in all
these other herbicides that are really
toxic stuff like chlorinated compounds
and things like that
they're going down and down and down but
check out weed resistance 2004 2005 and
2006. boom all those herbicides that
were really toxic including by the way
the other half of agent orange 2 4 d
is now being used to try and beat back
roundup resistant weeds wow and so
[ __ ] mess crazy watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify